[Music]
reanima is with us in a State College
Pennsylvania high Rianne and how are you
better than I deserve what's up yeah
just under a year and a half ago on my
father passed away and he left me with
some beneficiary money $100,000 are you
22 22 how old was he he was 45 Wow young
what happened yes he had a heart attack
and they pronounced him brain-dead about
a week or so later I'm so sorry
Wow but it was a year ago and he left
you $100,000 in year 22 yeah Wow
so what are you gonna do with it more of
it then I wish I had I need all my
student loans for my bachelor's degree
which is about 7,000 and I also bought a
a new car for about 27,000 which I
regret now and then also I've been
living also a lot of the rest of it I
was working and making money too but it
became a little bit too much to be
working and full-time at school being
you know in my junior and senior year um
so right now I have about fifty thousand
and six hundred dollars left in the bank
that money and how much I needed to
finish school I well what I plan to do
is I plan to become a physician
assistant and I will have to take
science because it's the program for
that is going to be about ten thousand
dollars so much school okay how much do
you need to finish school I'm about to
finish school in two months it's paid my
bachelor's is paid for but in total
60,000 and you have fifty thousand left
yeah I think we know what we're gonna do
with the money and then we've got to
figure out how you're gonna eat during
this time which means you are back to
work
yes and you're gonna be on a tight
budget watching what you're doing
because otherwise you're not gonna
finish school without that right you
make enough together and you make enough
to eat and pay your rent while you're
going through school and you have the
money to finish school
if you don't screw it up and go buy
something else you paid cash for a
twenty seven thousand dollar car yeah
it's so much I actually recently paid it
off I took out like a seven thousand
dollar loan to build credit and I just
recently just paid all of it off yeah
you could sell that
yeah and that's that's for I was
considering I was on kvv and it says
that the car's value is about twenty-six
thousand dollars now it's not you know
you haven't taken a given taken too much
of a bath for this mistake but honestly
the twenty-seven thousand dollar car in
your situation as broke as you are with
us with the goals that you have that are
much bigger than car ownership when your
education goals should be your dad's
legacy not a car by you a five or six
thousand dollar car and get yourself on
a tight budget and make sure you're
working and lay out a game plan where
your income will cover your housing and
food needs and and you've got the money
then to complete tuition and that that's
a good game plan and you'll you know and
what three years you'll have the degree
right yeah just about yeah from now and
you'll be a PA is that what you said
yeah that's what I'd like to be yeah
well I use are you getting the grades
can you do it I think so yeah I mean
it's gonna be there's gonna be tough
works especially working to but I think
I can do it okay one of the ways you you
can always test yourself and I've used
this with myself and with others too on
whether you're using an inheritance
properly is you visualize standing
beside the situation that you use the
money for and ask yourself is your dad
in heaven smiling and I see you standing
on that stage graduating with that PA
degree in your hand driving a three or
four thousand dollar car a five thousand
dollar car six thousand our car whatever
and zero debt and I see your dad's
smiling don't you yes I agree driving at
27,000 on her car not so much no that
makes sense
I just wasn't sure I'm always weary of
getting I was weary of getting a used
car because of the expenses that go into
it yeah it's been twenty thousand
dollars on a six thousand dollar car so
we know you're gonna come out ahead okay
and if you start spending too much on it
sell it you get a different one and you
know that's the thing
so yeah that's you know that's the thing
to think about it's just some ideas for
you I know you got some tough decisions
to make and you've been through a tough
time I'm sorry that this is left on your
plate but I'm really glad that $100,000
was left on your plate to to be able to
start your life off and you have the
opportunity to honor your dad's memory
by doing this properly and I think
that's something that calls us to more
nobility when we say that I'm not
shaming you instead I'm calling you to
nobility and what's the most noble
version of Rhiannon in this case and
it's the one that seeks out something
that's great for her future
not for her Friday night and that that's
the thing don't spend this money this
money is for your future and your
education and you graduate and you live
on a budget and you're responsible and
you're careful
hold on I'm gonna send you a copy of the
book the Total Money Makeover to walk
you through this process download that
every dollar app and get your budget
going look at where you can work you can
do your undergrad work and work most
people work while they're doing their
undergrad most people work while they're
doing their undergrad hey America did
you hear that
most people work while they're doing
their undergrad
this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]